zum meist gesuchten betrüger der welt
der ist auf freiem fuß in moskau
unterwegs unglaubliche geschichte es
geht um jan marsalek wirecard
milliardenbetrüger bka europol alle sind
hinter ihm her nicht ganz alle denn
putin der lässt ihn bei sich im land
ganz wunderbar leben und lieben der
blick aufs handy die haare kurz
geschoren die jacke rot eine auffällige
farbe für jemanden der eigentlich
unerkannt bleiben will jan most wanted
marsalek gesichtet in moskau es ist der
beweis deutschlands größter
wirtschaftsbetrüger ist im reich von
kreml tür an putin es ist die nächste
große enthüllung in der akte wirecard
der größte finanzskandal seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg und an der spitze der
österreicher jan marsalek rückblick das
zahlungsverkehrs
dienstleistungsunternehmen gilt jahre
lang als deutsches vorzeigeunternehmen
wird hofiert von spitzenpolitikern
darunter auch von der damaligen
kanzlerin angela merkel doch die
ereignisse des 19 juni 2020 stellen das
unternehmen und die deutsche finanzwelt
auf den kommen 1,9 milliarden euro
fehlen in der kasse des dax-unternehmens
verträge geschäft der weltweite konto
bewegungen alles erfunden die wirecard
aktie stürzt ab die gläubiger werden um
3,1 milliarden geschädigt und jan
marsalek flüchtet seine flucht führt von
vöslauer in österreich über minz bis hin
nach moskau auf seiner flucht wechselt
der milliarden-betrüger mehrere male
seine identität seitdem lebt jan maser
lag das luxusleben im land des kreml des
kunden genießt feinstes essen im
fischrestaurant marie fährt ein fettes
auto und lebt in einer luxusvilla nur 20
kilometer vom kreml entfernt dazu steht
deutschlands meistgesuchter betrüger
unter ständigen schutz von putins
geheimdienst seit juni 2021 soll massa
lag sogar russischer staatsbürger seien
seine neue identität gehrmann page rank
unfassbar wie bild im april exklusiv
berichtete erfährt der
bundesnachrichtendienst bereits im
frühjahr 21 wo sich jan marsalek aufhält
und informiert das kanzleramt darüber
außerdem bietet der russische
geheimdienst der behörde sogar an jan
marsalek zu verhören die reaktion ist
ganz leichtes stille keine reaktion die
enthüllung über janas alex genauen
flucht dort kommt kurz vor merkels
zeugenaussage in wirecard
untersuchungsausschuss wären maß alex
aussagen zum problem für die kanzlerin
geworden nach bild informationen hat der
bundesnachrichtendienst nach diesen
aufnahmen bereits erneut eine
auslieferung von jan marsalek beantragt
doch seit putins krieg in der ukraine
gilt diese als unwahrscheinlich
[Musik]